ça vous dirait une vidéo sur être
rejetée artesi oui je doute ce qui est
bien c'est que nous les jeudis en france
on a vraiment une image très classe faux
j'ai pas si vous le savez mais moi je
sors pour cent jeudi je suis né dans pas
de calais j'ai grandi dans les corons
mes grands parents et des mineurs de
fond dans la mine de charbon bref la
totale
comme beaucoup de gens du nord pour
accor jeudi du nord je veux dire
globalement des hauts de france
j'adore la cassonade et d'ailleurs je
déteste qu'on dise wes le sucre ou quoi
pour moi ça c'est une wassingue j'adore
les clapets la bière et je sais prononcé
potjevleesch enfin je crois
pour moi pleuvoir c'est trash et je
trouve qu'un terry c'est vraiment
magnifique et la couleur de ma peau est
la même que celle d'une endive
malheureusement nous les ch'tis on est
victime de certains clichés
sauf que pour beaucoup de gens en france
un ch'ti c'est un beauf consanguins avec
une coupe mulet qui s'appelle dylan fans
de tuning schwimmer raciste supporters
du rcl avec des tatouages johnny qui se
nourrit uniquement dans les baraques à
frites et qui déjà passé à trois
reprises dans l'émission confessions
intimes
tout ça est strictement faux madiot moi
par exemple juge qui ne correspond à
aucun de ces critères
à part peut-être que j'ai un prénom
américain mais ça c'est bon ok j'ai pas
d'arguments mon père aussi là un prénom
typiquement jeudi et s'appelle jackie o
moi ça me fait moyennement rire parce
que déjà c'est mon père et c'est
également mon deuxième prénom en même
temps les médias il est pas améliorer
l'image des ch'tis il pourrait de mettre
un petit peu en valeur mais les seules
ch'tis qu'on ne montre à la télé c'est
d'accord donc ce sont ces gens là qui
nous représente nickel pourtant on n'est
vraiment pas tous comme ça on dirait que
pour ses émissions ils ont pris une
poignée de ski les plus beau possible je
suis sûr qu'au casting de l'émission le
mec il devait être comme ça alors
prochain candidat pour l'émission les
ch'tis en thaïlande donc jordan 22 ans
va s'y présentent tous un petit peu en
quelques mots qui es-tu hauts-de-seine
ont été pris
pas besoin de faire les essais je te met
directement en vainqueur de l'émission
alors pour ceux qui en douteraient je
précise
pas parce que tu es gentil que terrain
bof c'est juste que comme le ch'timi le
bateau du nord est souvent associé aux
classes populaires
on a du mal à imaginer un boulot qui par
lâcheté mais pourtant c'est possible si
c'est chelou mai mais possible gerber
renshaw expo / pollock rouge mais drogba
atchoum brunch dans une baraque à frites
vegan cassiopée qu'aucun pas un chat
cassiopée arrête braire débris pudi
coopté veut faire ses voeux la critique
et de cloche chez christian dior et
cucchi tenait compte un pack à venir une
vie riche il faut apprendre le yoga à
l'eau a atteint mr connaught unités de
mâcon weight et du 16e à beyrouth
alors oui comme beaucoup de gens de
ch'nord je parle couramment chimie enfin
le jeu timide pas de calais mais bon
j'ai aucun mérite à tout simplement
refus des phrases qu'on faisait quand
j'étais petit à petit tarbes boucle des
voeux à une classe d'actifs
tu vas prendre mba teva bref autant mais
j'étais trop mal traitée en fait le
ch'timi c'est très cool mais il faut
avouer que c'est pas non plus le langage
le plus sexy du monde à disons que je
vois mal une pub méga classe genre
nespresso ou alerte mais version ch'timi
neige fraîche au cocktail ou de peluches
tout dit avec un choc cuillère cash note
de ch'nord mais comme j'adore le ch'timi
et que je pense que c'est un patois trop
méconnu je vais vous donner une mini
leçons du ch'timi mainini le sondage
timmy et pas de calais si je vous dis
mr comme ça ça veut dire moi je parle
comme ça moi devient me et ça devient
chaud d'ailleurs pour bien prononcé
chaud c'est un subtil mélange entre
chats des shows ça donne chaud mais
attention petit piège le chat l'animal
ne se prononce pas chômé corps là encore
un subtil mélange entre cas échos ce qui
donne corps du coup une phrase correcte
serait par exemple mais je parle comme
ça eschau schéma corps à part à
bienvenue chez les ch'tis on dirait que
les gens connaissent rien du nord c'est
dommage on dirait que pour eux elle est
hot france c'est juste un désert où il
ya rien à faire rien à visiter babelio
apte à faire votre don
bonjour est ce que je ferai visiter à
lens alors votre question qu'est-ce
qu'on a visités à lens bat ya un truc un
peu plus loin à vis talence cc lille la
ville de lille après je sais je sais pas
eh ben ça c'est encore une idée reçue
parce que figurez vous qu'à lens par
exemple il yal annexe du louvre où est
le vrai look de paris pour me demandez
pas ce que ça fulham et c'est là
maintenant le nord de la france c'est
devenu couleurs il ya même un film de
christopher nolan qui s'appelle
dunkerque
ces classes quand même j'avoue que
j'aurais jamais imaginé qu'un jour un
gros film américain va portant le nom
d'une petite ville de ch'nord
après dark knight interstellar et
inception
roubaix un film de christopher nolan et
bientôt la saga continue avec tourcoing
marcq en baroeul et montigny-en-gohelle
où l'aura compris les ch'tis c'est pas
forcément que des fans de tuning ou des
tuche 1
il reconnaissait peut-être même certains
évidemment dany boon mais aussi
marguerite yourcenar mathis alain decaux
ou le légèrement célèbre charles de
gaulle le nord de la france c'est le
musée naturel de l'épopée minière qui
inspire et emile zola dans l'un des
livres les plus célèbres au monde
c'est un geyser culturel avec lille3000
le mend square festival d'arras le
carnaval de dunkerque ou encore à la
braderie de lille ou encore le marché de
noël de strasbourg
mais bon ça ça strasbourg donc si vous
êtes des hauts de france vous devez
partager cette vidéo afin de lutter pour
notre cause et prouver au reste du monde
que nous les ch'tis on n'est pas juste
ça on a un peuple plein de ressources
connues pour notre chaleur humaine et
surtout bien loin des clichés qu'on nous
colle à la peau donc non désolé on n'est
pas consanguins moi les seuls qu'on sent
bien que je connaisse c'est les
lannister or nous on vient du nord
ciao biloute quand vous cliquez ici là
sur ce bouton depuis un téléphone ou un
ordi ça fait un truc nouveau alésia j ai
cliqué avec votre doigt ou votre souris
wall a pas mal an plutôt cool hyper
simple pour s'abonner beaucoup plus
instinctif donc merci monsieur youtube
et puis merci à vous je vous aime
énormément h et un petit poucet
[Musique]